no oh man oh he seems so upset I don't
even know it's just so difficult to
watch
[Music]
this but wait wait David David there's
been a big development because duol the
magician strikes again um we will see
the bar oh look at Magnus Carlson has he
blundered terribly Magnus Carlson
blundered with the bar will catch up
soon white is now suddenly two pawns up
I wrote him off too soon you Banker um
you're right you told me to wait I was
saying black was winning but he
[Music]
[Applause]
missed but can he hold this position
King B7 he's got to make sure to trade
the Queens otherwise he's going to get M
it oh is getting M oh man oh he seems so
upset look at him oh my god oh man I
would be upset too if I did that Bobby I
feel for you all right jumps are
appearing no K one nice move
here
wow we will show the end of that game a
bit later but look at this time Scramble
now yeah Magnus it looks like he blew it
he got over excited and dud is smiling
now and he blund he blunders into a
repetition of the position it's a draw
yeah it's completely hopeless
yeah and the body yeah King G2 King H3
you have to try yeah body language which
tells it all yeah po po
Maas I mean he knows that he he put up
incredible I mean he he tried everything
yeah and Maas
designs he's yeah he doesn't look so
happy beautiful it's a maximum checking
distance which is a term we use just to
say that the CH The Rook will check from
far away and now you this is important
give a check to the King Drive it away
and then you can pick up the pawn
yeah he picks up the porn and uh yeah
this one I'm just seeing it's popped up
there grind like a Grandmaster this is a
grind and end game grind worthy uh of
anyone prag his end game skills just Wow
Let's just remind everyone that means
that's your your chessable course which
people can now buy David right yeah and
we'll talk about that soon s but yeah
he's won this end game prag 360
turnaround from a losing position and he
won you King G8 we go Queen G6 Queen
takes H6 and then we will pick up the
pawn on D4 with checks and
anyway and yeah three against two
against one as we know sometimes is a
draw three against I mean two against
none three against none is kind of never
a draw
so yeah Wesley is positively encouraging
that Queen lift H yeah so The Black
Queen Under Fire and Magnus there okay
he moved his Mouse a bit frustrated
there is is his Mouse maybe clogged up
is his Mouse maybe a bit stuck sometimes
that happens right okay Magnus hitting
his Mouse there not happy at all maybe
the tracker for the mouse has gone a bit
astray oh yeah okay and we're probably
going to see him call the Arbiter
because that's uh one of the worst
things on online chess if your mouse is
not working very well okay he gives a
thumbs up that white piece is just
holding everything together blocking the
D line so why not just remove it okay
force it back so White Knight has to
move dude is slapping his own head there
he's not happy at all four seconds left
three okay he goes back to from but
that's an admission of defeat he's
basically just lost two moves there Duda
he's so devastated now seven points
ahead playing Mr
dropstone you really playing the
caran No No wor no wor you're good still
good go ahead go ahead go ahead goad wow
wow
wow can't believe I fell for that I
can't believe it and I ruined my shirt
in the
process
uh and the shirt yeah there we go Magnus
is going for it the king's going to
continue
advancing okay he doesn't no no but he's
this is a blunder oh Magnus has
blundered away his
Advantage we this is unbelievable yeah
he just walked into a double attack
simple check White's King will move and
then the white porn White's only winning
hope is going to drop off the board
White's extra Pawn is gone now on that b
line it's three pawns against three
pawns easy draw for black oh
yeah Wesley calculating extremely well
there um it looks like he did give up a
porn temporarily Black's weak porn has
actually just dropped off the board but
the knights have disappeared at the same
time and um oh look at Magnus he
realizes this is a blunder what's
happening W mag blundered his Queen it
took me a while to spot as well that was
visually very difficult to spot but oh
no he is extremely angry is this lost
now yeah that's lost and Magnus just
didn't have enough time that's an
uncharacteristic blunder he blundered
his Queen because he didn't keep the
white king safe on the back rank we'll
show that later on but right now black
is up a queen for just a rook and I was
wondering if well not you guys then
because you didn't see it but if people
at home who we've seen a huge blunder on
the bo by npia uh nomachi trying to
trade the Queens trying to head to an
end game but he's just missed this last
move white jumping in with his Knight
giving check and if that Knight is taken
then there are consequences White's
Queen will jump into the position
actually Black's about to lose either a
rook or a queen uh npom actually we see
it on his face um he did not even
consider that move okay this definitely
is kind of very very unpleasant because
Hikaru was just there I mean it was like
he he already put his foot uh inside I
can't even watch this video I mean I'm I
don't even know it's just so difficult
to watch this yeah I mean okay he's not
just pieced on and the king is King is
escaping yeah King goes back to G8
Knight will cover on G7 it's it's
resigned resigning time
white has no way to break through 26
seconds it should be enough for rajol oh
okay and that's it as a draw rajol is
through and T Mor rajo is the winner of
the quarterfinal match against Jana
Pachi and will face danil dubo in the
semi-final starting tomorrow
[Music]
wow